[Musique]
bonsoir en ligne on va mettre un peu de
côté ce conflit russo ukrainien vous
allez nous parler des convois de la
liberté au canada la contestation
s'apaisent les policiers ont dispersé
les manifestants la diffusion d'un
phoque sont toutes avec continue et on
va regarder une photo ensemble celle ci
celle d'une petite fille blonde qui
semble se dressait assez courageusement
face à une rangée de policiers le cliché
la circuler beaucoup pour faire écho
justement à la dispersion le week-end
passé paraît les forces de l'ordre des
manifestations donc du convoi de la
liberté l'une des légendes que l'on voit
ici en bas vas-y petit bats toi pour ton
avenir ce cliché il va être relayée ici
et là sur ton sur facebook twitter que
même sur tik tok est d'ailleurs cette
capture d'écran est assez intéressante
parce que vous voyez un peu l'effet
domino l'effet poupées russes ans un peu
de circonstance comment une fausse
information est relayée à tout-va relie
à cette capture d'écran relayé par ce
conte ici lui même relayé par cet autre
compte lui-même relayé par cet autre
compte et on retrouve aussi ce cliché
sur gab c'est un réseau social très
prisé par les militants d'extrême droite
et qui nous a affirmé c'est un peu
d'ailleurs ce qu'ont affirmé de manière
générale ceux qui partageaient ce cliché
que cette photo a été prise à ottawa au
canada donc et cet internaute dont de
s'émouvoir que cette fille est bien
combat le mal rien n'aurait peut-être
nous aider à y voir un petit peu plus
cher qu'en est il réellement est ce que
cette photo a vraiment été prise au
canada alors non on va revenir sur le
cliché virale il avait d'abord un indice
qui pouvait mettre la puce à l'oreille
regarder on va zhu vrai souci sur
l'écusson du policier on distingue deux
choses un mot polizei est aussi un logo
alors polizei ces polices en allemand
j'invente rien et ce qui s'apparente à
un ours debout c'est en fait l'emblème
de la de la police de la l'emblème
pardon de la ville de berlin et ce
blason c'est celui porté par la police
berlinoise est cette origine allemande
de la photo elle nous est confirmé par
une recherche d'image inversée voilà
d'ailleurs pour le blason en question je
vous renvoie sur le site des
observateurs pour savoir comment
procéder les résultats nous donnent une
dizaine d'occurrence en allemand et des
publications et des sites internet on
est en novembre 2020 une photos
partagées en pleine manifestation pour
dénoncer les mesures sanitaires en
vigueur déjà à l'époque la photo avait
été décontextualisés effectivement c'est
une autre recherche d'image inverser un
petit peu plus poussée qui nous conduit
à deux sites de fact checking allemand
dpa celui de l' agence de presse dpa et
d'une autre agence de presse afp et de
même face à la viralité de cette
information à l'époque la police de
berlin avait d'ailleurs publié cette
mise en garde parce que l'origine de la
photo la voix si regardez on est sur le
site de la ville de berlin et on est
plus précisément en 2018 pour les
journées portes ouvertes de la police
berlinoise et cette légende elle nous
explique tout alors j'ai essayé de me
sens tout faire bouger voilà elle nous
dit que ce sont des étudiants policiers
qui ont formé une chaîne comme il est de
coutume finalement dans les
manifestations et que l'on a demandé à
l'enfant de tenter de briser la chaîne
rien à voir donc avec le canada et la
situation actuelle mais c'est
intéressant parce que comme souvent on
joue sur l'émotion sur l'affect
finalement en s'appuyant sur un contexte
qui lui est bien réel et cette photo
elle n'est pas sans rappeler une autre
je ne sais pas si vous en souvenez celle
ci regardez cette femme tête haute
silencieuse face à des policiers c'était
le 9 juillet 2016 à baton rouge aux
états unis en louisiane après la mort
d'un jeune afro-américain alors la photo
elle est bien vrai le contexte était
bien vrai lui aussi mais elle était
justement devenue virale du fait de sa
charge un peu iconique le symbole de du
mouvement black light matters on peut
être tenté de chercher à transposer ces
situations riche en émotions va
retourner au canada avec une autre un
fox et concerne de cette fois-là la
police oui la police montée est
intervenue pour disperser les ce temps à
ottawa
et cette intervention d'ailleurs elle a
été très critiquée l'une des séquences
est devenue virale via par exemple ce
compte elle a été vue plus de 303 milles
fois regarder en bas de votre écran
plutôt à gauche vous voyez on va
s'arrêter voilà sur la femme c'est une
femme on ne dit ce n'est pas forcément
mais c'est une femme en rouge qui en
fait un déambulateur et qui on voit à
être tombé au sol alors la scène elle a
bien eu lieu à ottawa le week-end passé
mais la fa n'a pas tardé à être donnée
morte à tort sur internet et la rumeur
et si la rumeur s'est vite propagée on
voit ici la scène d'un peu plus haut si
la rumeur s'est vite propagée c'est
notamment à cause du tweet de cette
journaliste sarah carter une journaliste
de fox news qui compte plus d'un million
d'abonnés et elle nous dit que cette
femme vient de mourir à l'hôpital alors
on sait que fox tueuse a souvent été
considérée comme ils ont relayé des
fausses informations à plusieurs
reprises fausse information là le tweet
d'ailleurs a été supprimée l'intéressé
est revenu sur sur ce qu'elle avait dit
a reconnu une erreur et a même présenté
ses excuses dans un tweet et avant ce
rétropédalage la police d'ottawa avaient
elles aussi
n'ont pas reconnu une erreur parce
qu'elle ne s'était pas trompé mais en
tout cas fait des précisions pour
justement apporté un démenti quant à la
mort de cette femme et dénonçant par
là-même aussi une campagne de
désinformation à leur égard à son égard
pour merci beaucoup anthony on peut
retrouver votre connexion vos réseaux
sociaux même en podcast désormais qu'à
ce formidable merci anthony